I hear we have this in common you are a
homebody you'd like to be in bed by 9:00
yes I actually did not mean all the work
stuff that happens after that I'm like
you're not gonna get much you're not
gonna do anything
I get glassy-eyed and I just want to
have him snacks yeah tuck my shirt in
Timothy J Tommy night yep called night
getting bed and do this I love it and
here's I mean I love about you're so
normal when we were weird that ama's you
were hosting yeah and I was like oh my
god I love her I'm senior going up and
all the sudden I'm like why is the Ross
getting on stage with all her family I
was like I had no I
this is 2017 like that this happened and
I had no I I'm like a fan of you and I
had no idea I love that but that is that
career work no you're so good you're so
talented I had no idea and then it kind
of made sense the talent doesn't fall
far from the tree but I was like wow
then I was like you're so normal I would
have never guessed that you would have
grown up in Hollywood I would have never
gadget grew up in Hollywood I grew up in
my mom's house
okay and we weren't in Hollywood we
didn't we didn't live here only when I
was you weren't though and I mean I was
my mom is such a mom she's a mom before
she's anything else and so I just had a
really late yeah I'd like a really
regular upbringing a lot of siblings you
know I mean my mom was always like this
money is not for you
that's me I mean my kids are like wait
we have money I'm like no no no
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes I'll pay for doctors and make sure
there's a roof over your head shale a
certain point yeah and then go I'll pay
for health and education yeah nothing
else because you know what I turned out
just fine I didn't have anything my big
fear as a parent of having kids now we
have four kids my husband I grew up very
humble beginnings and we're always like
how did how do parents do it where your
kids don't turn out in rehab or like
something crazy
like it's the value of relationship the
value of family and the value of working
I mean my mom is a hard worker and you
know I learned all of that from her by
example not just pressure cuz she like
yeah you've got to be a good person
Kelly I'm trying tracing apparently I'm
not as good as Clio than I know crop
promises mom is gonna write a book and
help us all out please killing me in the
parent department it's fine but you big
news though you actually posted the
girlfriend driven a reunion right yeah
girl friends ran for eight seasons 173
episodes we were important to so many
people and it's been 11 years since
we've that we've been off the air and
surreal experience bringing the
girlfriends onto blackish it was like a
merging of worlds so yeah they are
coming on this season as my girlfriends
and I'm it was it was like no time had
passed I mean the love the giggles the
chemistry was like right back just right
back it was amazing do you in your
personal life have those kind of girls
too
absolutely you can't live without them
no oh my god my husband can't stand it
but I have so many female friend but I
but I feel like a lot of my best friends
their husbands know that like their
marriage doesn't work if it's not for
the friends but it's like the balance
like you want me you want me to help
balance this out okay and you're welcome
you're welcome
I talked her off the lab I have I have a
really good tribe of incredible
girlfriends I think you need that like
man women you just need that kind of
close circle that you can really just
bare all and be gross in front of them
mean if you want to just vent and then
it can see you and you can't see
yourself that can ground whole you out
you know I feel like one of my best
friends really anchors me to the best
part of myself and and really my friends
are people that I run things by when I'm
scared and I have to say that's the
beauty of text messages because you can
be in a room full of people having
really awful feelings inside that soup
of emotions and you can text your best
friends and get that shot of God of love
of support that Yuman with of humor
without anybody knowing yeah and so yeah
my friends are their key that's awesome
so your executive producing is it a spin
up and it just is all the way that
sounds
[Laughter]
it's amazing though it's lick stitch is
it okay to spin off its your game ain't
been off it's my character a flashback
so I am not physically yes it's a
prequel I am not physically that sounds
like perfumers and I don't know it
sounds like to come out okay yeah very
cool prequel um so it is flashback I'm
not physically on the show it is my
voice so it's my voiceover kind of like
Wonder Years remember Wonder Years with
you as a kid yes me as a course I
remember lovely young girl that is
playing me looks more like me than me
like it's really weird I'm like I'm
gonna get near me but she's so great and
yes it's it's a fish out of water comedy
and it's that story of what all of us
are dealing with when we're not like
everybody else in the room and how do
you how do you find out who you are and
hold on to that absolutely hundred
percent right yes you do this is my
favorite thing that you've been working
on the line for what 20 20 years of
dreaming 10 years of working on it I
wrote my first hair care brand pitch in
2008 when girlfriend's finished and it's
taken me ten years to make it happen oh
my god it is it is for me it is for
curly coily and tight textured hair it
is a community of people that have not
been supported and celebrated in our
beauty and our glory isn't it and yes
and we all know that key is products you
got to get products that work that
hydrate and and nourish your hair and
make it healthy and juicy and joyful and
that's what pattern my hair care
products
literally one of my favorite people ever
right okay we talked here we've talked
career we plug family body you have all
too because and I've seen these get it
really big and I've only are there three
cuz I'm see exactly five because you
know three what's the one with the lips
up to here and then I'd um Eva you're a
dear sweetheart
she likes to drink brown alga wait you
also have the wrapper right tea Murdoch
we know yeah tea murder and then there's
Calliope champignon is a fashion stylist
architect on and she never speak French
but she speak French with her English
with of concept oh my god that is so
sexy I don't even hear anything I'll
George was dialect it was so Meryl
Streep you just want Meryl Streep on me
just like brought out all these accents
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this